Axes approach to marketing has been one
of the most unique and brilliant
campaigns in history,
but their marketing genius has been
traded by what appears to just be a
cheap tactic,
advertising sex.
But what made it successful was not what
they were advertising.
Instead,
he was who they were advertising to and
how they did it.
By ignoring all social roles of
delicacy,
love them or hate them,
acts as a beautifully consistent brand.
Their marketing style matches their
product perfectly,
just like their cheap,
almost overpoweringly fragrant body
spray that punches you in the mouth
within stench acts as marketed to the
male ego with one singular thought.
Men especially pubescent boys don't
understand subtlety.
In fact,
it may never be possible to be clear
enough.
And so while other Cologne brands,
we're timidly dancing around the notion
that mindware fragrances to give women
acts decided skip the foreplay and go
for the Jaguar.
Their brand won't make you slightly less
smelly,
slightly more classy,
or make you fall in love.
Their brand will get you laid and not
just by one woman,
but as many women as you want and no six
pack required.
You can be the biggest loser in school,
but the second you spray on axe body
spray,
you become a chick magnet.
So powerful it would make James Bond
jealous all for the low low price of
four 99 but before they launched in
America in 2002 as a bottle of sex
pheromone x had to figure out who they
stood for.
After all,
if you try to appeal to everyone,
you appeal to no one.
So an efforts of figuring out the
perfect audience for their over the top
marketing campaign.
They decided to do a study.
Acts took nearly a hundred men out to
bars and watch them try to pick up girls
trying to classify different kinds of
potential acts consumers,
they eventually realized that their
target audience would not be the already
confident mail.
They didn't need help getting them.
They would sell to the awkward acne
faced average Joe who didn't have a
chance,
but the kind of guy who blushes at the
mere thought of approaching his crush,
the technical term for their audience
was the insecure novice.
And you can see this play out in their
ads.
Up until now.
Brands like old spice and colognes had
always cast male models to get the
female model but not acts.
They decided that with their body spray,
the Dorky male would get the female
model.
They cast it.
Anybody except the stereotypical hump.
It was the kid with glasses,
the average guy who's on an unlucky
streak.
But as for the female lead,
they applied,
their enough is never enough role and
Swan dove into the deep end of the nerds
fantasy life.
They consistently cast the perfect 10
Amazonia Bikini clad female lead doesn't
care that acts hasn't transformed you
into a hunk.
You don't need to be a hunt when you can
smell like a $5 candy backs.
And this has worked beautifully for a
long time.
And even right now,
access had the lion's share at the male
fragrance industry with the only real
casualty being high school hallways
everywhere.
But the way they did it wasn't just
selling sex acts reinvented how to sell
sex and who to sell it to.
Okay.